Oh welcome everybody to another YouTube
hang out super excited to be here again
with you it's a fun day today really
excited to have rip Phillips on with me
and rick is a communication expert and
we're going to talk about how to make a
persuasive pitch so whether you are
trying to talk to a customer trying to
talk to a partner or supplier whether
you're doing a pitch to a venture
capitalist or an investor whether you're
you've been invited to be on TV or
you're a judge at a competition you know
you have to get your message out there
and that can be really nerve-racking for
a lot of people and so brought on the
expert mr. rick phillips to help us out
Rick welcome aboard thanks Devon good to
be here for people who may not know much
about you can you just give a quick into
a quick bio background and then we'll
dive into some tips the easiest way to
describe myself as I'm a communication
coach in corporate trainer so I focus on
business communication skills it does
include interpersonal skills that
includes ESL and cultural communication
skills especially for immigrants and
foreign workers but business
communication skills that's what I do
that's what I'm all about so I have my
own company caribbean communications and
i'm also program advisor and co-founder
forget e which is the york
entrepreneurship development institute
by the name you can figure out we train
entrepreneurs and i'm also the newly
anointed executive director of a new
nonprofit called the National
Communication coaching Association of
Canada cool thought so when I think of a
coach I think of somebody who helps kind
of an ongoing capacity it's not like see
me once and then you're out but I need
help working through some of these
things and you know I may have a limited
skill set or I have limiting personal
beliefs and so if we apply coaching to
being an effective communicator what are
some of the blocks that people have that
you need to work with them through what
are some of the most common things that
you help people identify and overcome
well I'll tell you whether someone's
saying you know I have but communication
issues with my writing or I'm shy or my
boss I don't how to speak to my boss or
I don't know how to sell guess what they
all boil down
essentially to one thing which is
confidence hmm and so that's the thing
that it boils down to their certain
skills we can teach people some some
skills and we do I mean I'm a hybrid
coach so I my backgrounds teaching me so
I do offer training I do different tips
and theories as well as the other side
of coaching which is you know getting
them to ask themselves questions
motivate them powerful questions get
bored but at the end of the day it's
about confidence if you're confident in
who you are in your position wherever
and you can handle yourself in any
communication they're setting that's
that cuts deep man I can find a deep I
bet you died so how how do we improve
our confidence because I guess I mean
that applies to a lot of things not just
in communications but applies to a lot
of areas of our life how do we improve
our confidence as a person well so I
mean without going off the beaten track
of what I'm what I'm trying to do which
is communications competency leads to
confidence and so when we narrow that
down to the communication world becomes
that's my specialty let's take
presentations at work you know or
interviews for that matter someone says
I'm not very good at this and I'm gonna
forget that's obvious that wears down on
the conflicts understood so maybe we can
improve their skill set with their
technical skill set with the
presentation with Pamela give you
questions and you know their body
language their voice the words all that
stuff and their competency races because
they have a new paradigm so before they
were invented themself let's say six out
of ten and then after training into
practice we get seven of ten seven and a
half then they have a very successful
interview or presentation eight so the
competency leads to confidence to answer
your question directly I focus on
communication skills as a way to do that
John but you have to know the right
things to focus on to write like
practicing the wrong thing over and over
again you get great at the wrong thing
how true how do you identify what they
should be getting competent in yeah I
reminded of a saying it's not practice
makes perfect it's perfect practice
makes perfect right so I mean that's
where you get help right I mean that's
why someone might hire a culture trainer
like myself because they say i only got
so far can you help me out and I mean I
would say that of course keep a lot of
resources online
books workshops but at the end of the
day if you have a Taylor private coach
working working with you the knots up to
the best way to do it so so it's about
acknowledging first that you have some
issues or ever quite frankly somebody at
work tells you like the manager said
look like King we want to keep you but
you know you've got improve your
communication skills you've got to
improve the way you talked before you
got to improve your presentations
obviously then they know there's an
issue but they don't know as you said
what is the issue so they better get
help and that's when coaches like myself
come in we do the assessments we work
with HR we do all the all the fun stuff
that we have to do to set a plan in
action and give them a core program with
curriculum and Taylor as best we can to
wear everyday life so for looking at
kind of improving our confidence through
the competence are there other certain
common common themes through that like
common issues that people have with
their confidence that you have to kind
of you see over and over and over again
and I mean it's a different person each
time but are there like common themes
that come through that you think applied
a lot of people who are having struggles
I think you know it's um it comes down
to sometimes the weather we judge our
self from within as we're successful
we're good we're okay or whether we look
for external acknowledgement from our
bosses from our parents from anywhere
else and I'm not saying that one's
better than the other but there's a
balance there and so quite often when
large confidence is shaky because one of
those is kind of upset a bit so if
you're at work or if you're an
entrepreneur and you are doing
everything on your own shoulders like a
lot of entrepreneurs photo you sometimes
you only got yourself to measure are you
doing good or not and you have to get
that external reference to say yeah I'm
okay and this leads us back to things
like mentoring Santino to getting of
building a team as opposed to doing it
yourself there's a there's a bunch of
things that stretch out here in to use a
lot of entrepreneurship so confidence is
part of the you know psychology and live
culture and all that stuff there's real
hard skills to that anyone can learn
it's almost like learning on your
financial projection you can learn how
to do a better presentation you can
learn to be more persuasive and then you
try it on and you work it and you get
some role models and you try it on it
eventually becomes very comfortable with
you
so if I think back to myself like I've
done 3,300 something videos now in the
YouTube channel not all them are public
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
work and I feel like I just I did the
work to get through but maybe I could
have been smarter and doing the work
like maybe doesn't have to take you
three thousand videos I get good and I
think back to when I was starting you
know just launched my first videos I had
a DSLR camera that wouldn't focus so i
had to have somebody focus it on me
right i would have to have them focus
leave the room and then like press
recording then leave the room because
because I was worried you know how they
would judge me i guess like I couldn't I
couldn't be myself in front of the
camera when somebody else was around me
right even if it's like my wife or
something on my team or like my sister
somebody who I knew well I still
couldn't do it the product was always
substandard what advice would you give
to like that Evan trying to get started
cuz i think a lot of people are not
position not everybody's used to having
a youtube channel being successful but
they want to be more confident i think
public speaking is one of the big stink
biggest fears for people so like going
back to that Evan what kind of advice or
questions or like what would the process
be for you to help coach me through that
sure that's a great question well that's
the first thing I would tell you or any
other client or a friend I would say
first of all the before we get into
technical skills genuine it is most
important if you're honest and genuine
with what you're trying to deliver the
audience whether it's online or in
person feels that you're being genuine
and sincere that is eighty percent of a
right there in others what I'm saying is
that it's better to be honest and rough
around the edges which videos then to be
so polished because you practice the
politicians know certain types of grips
and all that stuff but then people who
fake because you're not doing any even
ohms and oz which reminds me people say
oh you know if you're a good protector
and public speaker don't say any alms
and odds that's absolute crap because to
be human is to once a while catcher get
your thought well well no what I'm
saying is and so definitely to be
genuine the first
I would tell you rate my house the
second thing is you know I called my
company 3d communications for a reason
there's three beads and communication
and verbally which is your words your
grammar syntax slang vs formal language
globally which is your paralanguage so
it's your rhythms speed volume
information and visually which yes its
body language gestures but it's also
anything they can see so it's anything
in the background like your background
of your video it's difficult woman has
jewelry on or I have look I have a ring
on it it's a symbol of some kind doesn't
it if I have my office set up a certain
way so so visual communications
obviously the strongest part of that so
I would tell the first look let's just
take a couple things from each category
like verbally let's make sure we're
speaking confident where it's not you
know subcom but it's still for example
say things like I am I will is a little
stronger than saying you know I'm not
sure maybe I'd like but not know so the
little bit of that vocally it's medium
volume medium speed you know don't rush
because then you look like you're in a
hurry don't go to slopes it looks like
you're struggled for thought and I would
also suggest chunking on the words so a
lot of people they go from they want to
get it all done especially during a
pitch I would say think of great
speakers politicians Barack Obama for
example it's like four or five words
break four or five words of three or
four words cause so chunking it up is a
great way to practice and then verbally
or visually there's a lot of bottom line
the ship's I can view but the basics is
not just white people what not to do so
on YouTube videos since you brought it
up some people aren't looking off where
they look if you're looking for the
script they've got on the wall on the
whiteboard off the side there looking
down to their notes because they've got
notes here they're looking up in a way
because they're sort of thinking to
themselves which although is natural you
can't get away with it much too much so
I would think it was like bunch of of
what what to do but also people what not
to do it's coms breathing it's good
posture flowing your hands from the
center point is a very natural way to do
it without trying to be jerky I mean
that's the general if I had coaching
time with somebody I could work through
their specifics right I got to remember
that hands to the center point next week
video day
into the center point i'll try to ever
that cuz it's a really good stuff man
politicians use it to let don't let who
it sounds small but very effective I
like it and then so you know there's a
whole is mean you already said a ton of
value tons of things and people to think
about is it trying to practice one thing
at a time like okay you know what this
week I'm going to focus on hand to the
center point you know not going too
crazy and that's all I'm going to focus
on and then move on to the next thing or
is it like okay you're the five things
I'm trying to remember all of once and
go through that I mean when you ask me
questions I think about is if someone
asks me the question so so empathy is
really important for coaching so I
immediately put myself in that position
as the quarter Pole of student my answer
is according to my learning style so I
would sit back to anyone else i would
definitely don't want to overwhelm
somebody i mean there's no point saying
here's 15 things learn them by next week
for your next Toastmasters meeting right
that's to me a silly two or three is a
nice number and you know if they want to
break it down even further why don't you
think I've got no problem with that it's
about their comfort it's also for
example some people may have studied
dance or gymnastics for theatre arts
before even in high school and that
stuff stays with them so they're more
comfortable with certain body motions
somebody else may have just a naturally
beautiful speaking voice they're not to
work on that too much so it depends what
skills that they already have and again
if this is why it's good to have
somebody tell them this is what's great
this is what needs to work and you know
whether it's a professional coach or
whether it's a mentor in the business
world to give them some feedback
obviously able to get a coach because we
trained to pick these things out and
we're also trying to tell people what
the friends don't tell them so it's
useful to have that I remember when I
was first getting started I had to read
a script it had to come up from script
and and to your point was not genuine
and and you could say it was like I was
super nervous and looking off just
trying to remember what I was saying
doing someone he takes yeah and I
evolved to be much more of the style
more empathetic and just more myself and
I remembered two weeks ago I had to do a
video with brian tracy we did a
collaboration right um he's like sex
success expert and goal setting guy and
he had a set
traduction in a set conclusion that he
wanted me to do and then like the points
that I wanted to make and the set intro
conclusion were like 20 seconds each but
it took me so many takes to get them
though I was saying the wrong thing and
I couldn't remember the words and then
and then my five points which was the
bulk of the video I just go like talk
about it and be genuine that was
definitely a evolution in the process
for me in terms of getting there faster
for people there's the fear that you
know okay I'm not going to say the right
thing you know like I have it written
down perfectly if I say it just like
that it's going to be great but then you
lose the emotional connection because
you're just trying to memorize a script
instead of saying you know speaking from
the heart so that fear of saying the
wrong thing or not giving value in the
pitch in the interview in the
presentation is it i like how do you
overcome is just against to the practice
or how do you like how do you get over
that that like you have value to provide
even if you say the wrong words like the
words are as important as the intention
and the meaning behind it yeah that's
think it's a great question and it's
easy for me to answer so to speak I'm
very much anti script and and so with my
client with myself obviously with my
clients and some of my clients react not
too well when they first hear that in
the first session so they think the
question is what's the solution because
as you said there are certain key points
we want to get out we don't want to have
our 5-minute or 10-minute picture I give
you done and we've done i forgot to say
something looking for so of course you
have to have some kind of scallops in
some kind of bullet points absolutely
but having will appoint literally will
appoint notes of phrases no real sense
is whatsoever can give you talking
points of things you have to catch but
still keep a conversation without
reading the script now if we switch this
to presentation how many powerpoints
have you seen that have sentences in
though that have their full text right
and then the guy or girl are reading it
as well like flip to the next slide and
it just read it with you like why am i
listening to you but he's read this
hole it becomes not a slide and not a
document becomes a sly comment as was
said by gar Reynolds from presentation
Phyllis you know it's like it's so so
the discipline is required and i would
say that with my clients the people have
great technical skills so they're
doctors lawyers politicians IT
professionals finance um you know people
with PhDs and masters god bless them but
they they some of them have a hard time
letting go of that because I really want
to be technical and thorough and their
fact or engine and you say look you can
make these slides really simple just a
couple words pictures you know and just
speak the code and that first sometimes
have trouble trusting me but when you do
them off and go with them as I do they
always you'll find that it's better in
the end so that leads to one of my big
tips for today which is that
presentations of any time you know this
should be mostly pictures on the slides
very few words no sentences you can put
instead of saying you know fifty percent
of adults are afraid of public speaking
as a sense just put fifty percent just
the number fifty percent and then people
look and their brain starts thinking
what does fifty percent me so you're
stimulating wrong and you're keeping
them engaged and then you say did you
know that according to the world no
statistics fifty percent of people are
afraid of public speaking so it's little
things like that where you can still get
trim that message that baby come 2.1
notes that we talked about are very
important to make sure you keep watcher
cause but the slides are engaging and
and it works for you and it works
without they keeps you natural I'm
thinking about I'm thinking back the
confidence how we let off the the chat
and I think back to when I was doing a
lot of pitches or meetings even meetings
like when I was meeting somebody it was
always in a suit and tie right always
suit and tie still dressed nicely and
then it slowly like evolved or now you
know I got my hoodie on you know I
didn't shave today it's like I don't
care like I know that if I don't care
others won't care and and it's just
bringing value like if people can see
that I'm bringing value that's all the
others are going to care about I used to
worry a lot when I went on when i did my
first media i figure who was with it's
like sweating
bullets and panicking like the lights
are on you is like I have 15 seconds to
say something you know two hours of
waiting and then you got your 15 seconds
of fame there and now it's like I don't
I don't care like I I appreciate the
opportunity but i don't i'm not i'm not
worried about the judgment of the
reporter I'm just trying to figure out
like where did that come from is it is
it just that I've done it so much or is
it like a mindset shift or yeah it's a
paradigm shift from competency from
doing it so much and getting feedback
either internally from your own internal
reference of success or externally from
interviewers or audience is saying hey
Evan that was great that was a great
interview you know and then your friends
say yeah I was creating then you go okay
I guess because we're looking for in
your head it's always going to be works
always any type of public speaking like
correct the great mounting to myself oh
my gosh might am I saying what I want to
say a mic it am i coming across what I
want to but I know that whatever's in my
head it's not as bad as what the reality
is how do I know that always your
experience in confidence to come from
competency so getting back to your point
I've done the same thing with interviews
and it's the same thing just going to
show up in at some point to say I'm
going to be me and I don't think that I
don't think I've ever want to try on a
media cute bike I still concern myself
at least looking nice and I'm not brave
enough to show up in shorts yeah but one
day I like when what made you want to do
this like what what makes Rick wanted
become a communications codes like why
does that mean something to you you know
that's it that's a darn good question i
think i'm part of it is it's just how I
developed it from my career path so the
first part of it is just uh you know I
have like many people you work different
jobs and my background social sites you
know social psych at university and you
know teaching English in the second
language and worked in an office and I
didn't like the cubicle lifestyle even
always good at if I didn't I didn't
really see me no offense to anybody was
in if it wasn't me and I was just sort
of stuck there for saying like those you
know what am I going to do do I go back
to the office world where I can make
some money but I'm already happy or do I
keep doing this that doesn't make me as
happy and I just talked to a friend and
he'd mentioned life coaching and I we
did a bunch of research on that and then
I figured I didn't want to be a life
coach because I wasn't old
in my own opinion I was I thought to me
electrical should be at least over 40
and I at the time I wasn't and I thought
but wasn't caught my eye was that of the
community of the life coach Akers
segments you can focus on which of
course is communications and then it all
came made sense of Michael G I know
people in groups like social in
psychology like I get that I good at
teaching on you know I've worked with
immigrants are you know and it just came
all came together and then I have a
little bit back on an acting nothing
professional but it all leads to help
you communicate with confidence and so
is put together and then I vote we just
try and I had enough under my belt to
start out in 2006 and I just had a basic
template website and I just started out
and I wasn't charting very much but I
had a few companies and a few
testimonials of people I was working
with and I just went on and I just know
ball and then you then I sort of I sort
of followed where it led me but at the
same time I was researching constantly
this like everyone else for reading
books you're taking courses you're
learning more both whatever public
speaking presentations have been uh it's
personal skills Dale Carnegie anything
you can do and then as I got better and
better i got i was able to get more
focused and and then i got confident and
at some point if you said i'm just going
to really go after what I'm really good
at I'm not going to chase things that
are sort of interesting but I'm only
forty percent good at I just said if I
stick to what I'm good at what I know
would I understand what I'm experienced
in I can be successful i can charge a
corporate affairs i can i can get people
to respond respect me and that's what i
do and then I remember like the first
time I had like big meetings that big
companies for the first time I remember
you don't walk into he's a you know
multi-millionaire guy he's looking at me
go on like how are you going to help me
you know I've read this pump money and
that was our most question you asked me
by the way and I remember when TV so
then I put up but you handle it and you
get the contract that gives you to
another level of confidence was there a
moment maybe I guess before you started
your business that uh maybe you weren't
great at communicating and then you you
really want to get better and like that
then made you want to help others get
better like the why behind it that were
you always a great communicator or
they're like you sucked at the start and
had to work on it yourself and
and eventually got better um yeah I'd
love to be able to say that I was a
terrible speaker and I was shy as a kid
but that wasn't true in my case I know
it's a great story but it's not true um
I was always outgoing I was always each
or personal I was always good at making
friends um staying in contact people I
was joining theatre arts and stuff when
I was a kid but I can certainly tell you
that I mean I was a terrible listener I
didn't know that of course i had
terrible empathy skills I didn't treat
people you know the right way like
ex-girlfriends are probably like you
know sneering at right now going you a
general communicator what are you
talking about like this sorry I was so I
mean but you know I can certainly see
why because I've been through I've
learned a lot more studying for I looked
at other people ever oh yeah so I didn't
have the background that some people did
where they were driven into the career
for me it was it was a matter of me
saying what skill sets and interest you
i have but i can put together that i can
create a successful business because
then i'll be happy and it was really
about following your passion both not
doing a job that he didn't like that for
me was the drive I didn't want to do in
job just for money that I didn't like
and I said I'm gonna do this
entrepreneurship thing and even if I
don't know what I'm doing and that's
what I am and I said what do I don't and
this is how I started love it let's grab
a couple questions real quick in the
last few minutes Chrissa is asking i
hope i pronounced that okay is there an
average time where someone will be able
to improve his or her communication when
they go through that kind of coaching I
think people learn immediately I think
that any type of coaching I'm not going
to limit it just to communication skills
you learn immediately so why because if
you're motivated so if you first of all
up here not being forced to go there
because your boss or your father said
you have to go to this course that's
obviously a different story but if
you're motivating yourself you're
showing up and you have an hour session
hour and a half whatever it might be
there's going to be at least one or two
things are going to take away from that
it's going to either a live gig
introspective or two no libraries say
I'm going to try this one thing so I
would I I do believe and I'd say that
with all honesty thing that you will
pick up at least we're into things each
time if you have a confident coach or
trainer will you learn every single
thing they talked about
memorize and be purpose of course not
everything takes time you gotta fake it
to make you better go into it but we've
always things will pick up quickly based
on your natural skill sets for your yeah
I like it yeah i think i think the 8020
will probably applies to whether some
things that you pick up super quick and
a good coach will find the the quick
wins for you to immediately apply so
that you can feel like you got momentum
going on but then there's also other
ones that are probably like deep-rooted
fears that you know will take some time
to work through and that's probably not
the first thing to tackle you tackle the
easy stuff first and what's it easy for
something might be hard for somebody
else just depending on your background
and experiences exactly i mean i like a
lot of my courses are actually i would
say relatively short like the actual
programs people are expecting you to
coach for years and that's not the way
it's set up there are clients i have
after years but it's not set up that way
an initial problem is very focused you
know five six sessions 8 12 sessions
hour and a half once every two weeks you
know less than six months you're done at
least the core program there may be some
follow ups and stuff because i don't
want a client who is addicted to me i
don't want to be the person that's not
doing my job right that they need me for
a year i want to go you know tweak them
and whether it's the water range the
presentation whatever it's going to be
and so we can have fast action through
the Yeti the program i work with you
know we teach entrepreneurs very quickly
how to pitch in five minutes five minute
pitch four slides I got even you got
them for a four hour lecture i keeps
them and then some one-on-ones and then
we're ready to go right in front of you
know very different of people so yeah my
style certainly is not to drag it on its
to give them as much information as we
can and then work with them in golden as
fast as possible cool Mary's writing in
thank you Rick very interesting I have a
question what do you think of reading
notes during a pitch so we kind of
touched on that but but to dress Mary's
question reading notes during a pitch
what do you are [ __ ] I'm against any
type of reading of any kind unless it's
just a couple key words off your slides
and that can be coffee shop you have
your laptop or tablet oh but a coffee
shop you're pitching someone just know
there's a couple key words on the tablet
you can say by the way this is the key
thing it's almost like reading the
slogan
of your company although I would assume
you've got that memorized by now so just
in general my rule is that short words
like maximum forwards think of it that
way or you know like i said before
having a number as a comp fifty percent
as opposed to sentence you do the same
thing with with the keywords and then
that will keep you going give you some
structure but every time you put your
head down to read notes you're breaking
eye contact you're breaking the whatever
God you might have fun with the audience
of people so try your best if you really
really have to because you're just not
there yet minimize as much as possible
short as notes as possible like do
everything you can to wean yourself off
the the habit of meeting notes love it
question coming about the 3v so I think
it's the 3ds not the 3 v's do you have
more information on is it 3 v's yeah oh
I got it wrong please good so so you're
right that's my bad yet so they're
asking do you have more a bigger break
down with that like a white paper or
something they can download to learn
more about the 3ds okay um all my
website there's like I me about about Us
page of the about about three beams and
i'll even go through thee it tells you
just sort of what i told you already
which is at the basics of what he comes
to them it also tells you about an old
study that was done in about nineteen
sixty seven by Albert Mehrabian which
was originally came up with this
principle people sometimes boat called
the seven 3855 rule and the seven 38-35
rule was based on a very small study
done back in the 60s which was measuring
communication of attitudes and feelings
that were communicated between two
people and seven percent was considered
to be worse based on the research
thirty-eight percent was voice and fifty
five sevenths face so that was a very
small study about 20 or 30 people at
college but that's the basics of what
we're talking about so I've expanded
obviously to include a more than that I
do quota 738 55 rule as a reference
point by double whole to it as a
scientific fact from all communications
I just generally say but we can agree
that it's not what you say it's how you
to it right okay so we agree the
nonverbal stronger than verbal right
and I just kind of keep it like that but
didn't people want to have more research
beside where of my website and blog
might offer they may look up dr album
ready and just look at his research to
see me he came up with well one extra
question I had is you know you mentioned
Obama and the the forwards and then
pause forwards and pause and if you look
at you know great public speakers I'm
sure there are some things that they all
have in common than some things that
they find their own style off of right
you look at Martin Luther King I don't
know if he does the forwards maybe does
definitely has a lot more passion than
Obama might have and so I get that as a
communications coach part of your job is
to hey dis still all of this stuff that
works for successful speakers and then
you know trying to teach that to people
to improve themselves once we learn like
the foundation is it how to identify
like who I can model best like if I'm
more of an Obama guy or a Martin Luther
King guy or a JFK guy or Justin Trudeau
guy or like whoever these great speakers
are how can identify somebody that like
fits well with who I am as a speaker to
try to model well I mean I'm going to go
back to without trying to give you a
lazy answer I'm gonna go back to who you
attracted to you know as a speaker like
when you're watching newscasters which
speakers do you like to listen to even
the news if you go to ted talks and TEDx
who you like you know even saying Obama
and Martin Luther King both great
speakers both use that broken up rhythm
but different points ready to be Martin
Luther King use you know that was a very
emotional speech obviously and a lot of
that would stop come but because he had
so much experience with a certain style
of a Baptist pastor style he was able to
you know deliver that in such an
effective way and Obama i also had
experience with the baptist church and
he knew how to do that as well he
incorporates some of that introduced to
speeches so i need to join a cop this
church they don't it's not it's not the
worst thing to do but i'll tell you what
if anyone's kind of think of themself
about just generally speaking three P's
revisable giving tips for persuasion and
any type of pitch or speaking I would
say it comes down to you know emotions
do you have emotions connect to it are
you hitting
the kind of pain point or pleasure point
presently that we're going towards
pleasure we're running away from pain so
either you're connecting with the
audience's pain and what they want to
avoid or what they can get if they
follow you and buy your product that's
the first thing is the emotional appeal
second of the logical appeal that's like
the numbers or the sales or the how is
it can be or the statistics canada says
blah blah blah so that's your numbers to
back up your logical appeal the third
one is credibility to credibility of poo
of you the speaker you know do we know
yours why should we believe you or your
company so if you want to break it down
in this computer for elevator pitches
for networks for any type of pitching if
nothing else if nothing else think of
those three elements and you can do in
30 seconds or like you know 10 minutes
ago you know emotional appeal logical
appeal and your credibility and that
will give you get you a long way I think
I love it tons of value Rick thank you
so much for spending time with us thank
you guys for watching to learn more
about Rick communication coach that's CA
on Twitter it's calm coach to ms I've
linked that up in the description to any
any other place to reach you Rick I mean
I've been a YouTube channel home coach
73 and you know it's that's that's
that's enough linkedin of course i'm on
linkedin such as wherever you want to
find you i'm happy to connect awesome
well thanks just the time again thanks
for watching go check out Rick's website
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon thanks so much